ran into all my babies
on their walk
hi babies
not only is Kylie Jenner mom to
five-year-old daughter stormy and
one-year-old son air she's mom to seven
yes
seven dogs two I'm obsessed with it so
on Wednesday the beauty Mogul shared
this clip to her insta story
ran into all my favorite
baby on their walk
hi babies
count them that's one two three four
five six seven Greyhounds people oh
Normie norm and Kylie Kai back in 2014
Kylie welcomed her first Greyhound
Norman to the fam
what's Norman's middle name Wimbleton
Norman Wimbleton after that she got
another Greyhound named Bambi and the
pups even had their own Instagram
account I love it since then it appears
Kylie has added a few more furry friends
to the pack hi baby foreign
and speaking of babies the reality
star's first born human baby just
celebrated a major Milestone the proud
mama shared this snap with stormy on
Wednesday riding alongside it my sweet
girl graduated Pre-K today come give me
a big hug
[Music]
I love you Mommy
forever of course Kylie shares stormy
and air with her on-again off-again Beau
Travis Scott their latest break
confirmed by a source in January who
told ET Kylie and Travis lived different
lives Kylie's more of a homebody while
Travis likes to go out and party and
that's been a big issue
in March A source told E.T that Kylie
was trying to stay positive and wanted
things with Travis to remain drama-free
and last month our source said Kylie and
Travis are still cordial they're focused
on co-parenting and being the best mom
and dad they can be
meanwhile things have been heating up
between Kylie and Timothy chalamet a
source telling E.T earlier this month
that the two like each other and have a
good vibe between them that's what it is
to uh be young they're still taking
things slow she's enjoying this time and
seeing where things go she is being
mindful of her kids as her main priority
is always being a great mom
thank you
foreign